in our you've got to be kidding me story
of the morning NASA is now responding to
criticism after announcing the first
ever all-female spacewalk will not
happen this week because only one
appropriately sized space suit is ready
unbelievable astronauts and McLane and
Christina cook were set to make history
Friday by walking together to install
lithium ion batteries for the space
station solar panels the project will
still take place but a male astronaut
will walk in Maclean's place Janet
shamlian explains NASA astronauts and
McLane and Christina cook might have to
wait a bit longer to walk into the
history books the first all-female
spacewalk will not go on as planned
because of an issue with the size of the
spacesuits onboard the space station
McLane trained at a large suit on earth
but on a spacewalk last week she wore
the medium
she told NASA it gave her more mobility
which is needed to replace the batteries
the problem there's only one medium suit
configured for a spacewalk and cook also
wears that size although they have
others in storage it would take 12 hours
to prepare another one it makes a lot
more sense to let them continue to
concentrate on visualizing their tasks
doing all those things to get ready as
opposed to trying so hard to make sure
we stick to the same crew astronaut Nick
Hague will now join cook on the six and
a half hour mission the most important
thing to me is that there's you know two
crew members that are comfortable that
go out the hatch complete the activity
successfully and make it safely back
inside so obviously that's my number one
priority
many criticize the change on social
media including Hillary Clinton who
tweeted make another suit NASA says a
future spacewalk involving both women is
still possible
earlier this month McLane talked about
the importance of future generations
seeing female astronauts taking lead
roles it's important for a lot of people
to look out and see someone that looks
like them fewer than a third of NASA's
38 astronauts or women cook will become
the 14th American woman to walk in space
out of more than 200 spacewalks total if
I can be an inspiration to any child
that wants to grow up and get into the
business of space exploration then I'm
not totally thrilled to do so for CBS
this morning
Janet shamlian look we all love Nick
Hague here right we love him but I'm
sorry you can't get a medium suit in
less than 12 hours may take ulis another
suit just just nip it tuck I mean you
know yeah stitch it whatever you do have
to call us call it at NASA and MacLean
safety pins yeah and we'll get our turn
very soon